we're live we got the right slides are
ready to go hi my name is Phil Burnett
again I'm the executive director of
design program we're going to talk about
design thinking and applying it in the
workplace so the first the first thing I
want to start with is sort of a quote
from ours our our senior academic a
person David Kelly David's also the
founder of the d.school our Institute
for design thinking here at Stanford and
prior to that was the founder of IDEO
which is probably one of the world's
premier sort of innovation consultancies
and David is the sort of big thinker
behind the Design Thinking idea we had
been teaching design as Stanford for
over 50 years the design program that I
run which has both an undergraduate and
a graduate degree program in it you can
get an undergraduate degree and
mechanical engineering and product
design and you can get a graduate degree
in design both from the mechanical
engineering school that program started
in 1963 and we've been working in this
very multidisciplinary radical
collaboration methodology for a long
long time but around 2004 2005 David
came up with the idea of moving our work
into a wider domain of problem solving
for everybody so reframing it as a
method of thinking design thinking and
he's been quoted in his TED talk and in
his book on creative confidence and
saying we believe that the next
generation of innovators and leaders
need to be great design thinkers and
Design Thinking is just that it's just a
way of solving problems David will
describe it optin is just another tool
in your tool belt
just because you master the principles
of design thinking doesn't mean that you
give up on you know using other powerful
methods scientific method engineering
thinking and the methods of making
decisions that you're taught in a sort
of a business school or business kind of
thinking but Design Thinking works
particularly well on large scale
multidisciplinary
problems where it's really difficult to
get clear boundary conditions and lots
and lots of data typically other methods
of making decisions require that you
have good data in order to make good
decisions in the case of design problems
you almost never have any data because
you're really projecting and designing
things that are going to occur in the
future and as we all know you can't get
data on stuff that hasn't happened yet
anyway we talk about the workplace I
want to sort of maybe demystify this and
with the potential of oversimplifying it
you know work is just a place where
people go everyday and it's organized
typically around certain tasks that have
to get done
certain certain vertical tasks like
marketing manufacturing operations
design engineering research and then
it's organized around the skills that
people have in those different domains
and really if you break it down you know
the culture of any organization is just
this collection of behaviors what do we
do when we get to work do we go to lots
of planning and budget meetings we go to
lots of meetings where we talk about
stuff or do we spend most of our time
designing building you know creating and
when you if you're talking about
transforming the way you work and when
we have the master series class on
campus I get a chance to me with 60 70
people almost every time and they're all
in different kinds of work environments
in the financial industry in the design
industries in in hospitality and finance
you name it and they talked to me about
the things they do at work and mostly
they say that the stuff that they do at
work doesn't feel as productive or as
generative as it could be and they're
very interesting in learning about
design and design methods to sort of try
to supercharge the innovation and just
supercharge the environment and so I
always come back to well if you want to
transform your work what you're really
saying is I want to do different things
when I get there so we're really talking
about what are the behaviors that you're
going to change and one of the skills to
children
boy with these new behaviors to kind of
change the way work occurs for you and
you know we think that you change those
things by first training yourself up on
these new ideas that design thinking and
then essentially modeling these new
behaviors when you behave like a
creative person your staff your team
other people see those behaviors and
they want to emulate your particular if
you're in a leadership position so you
know creativity is not a very magical
thing it's actually a pretty simple
thing to understand all humans are
naturally creative we're tool makers and
builders by nature unfortunately a lot
of your education in the u.s. anyway has
some and a beaten creativity out of you
and there may be you know bureaucratic
structures or ways of working which also
limit you what you think is this
possible scope of creative behaviors at
your work but I think if we just focus
on you know these kind of ideas about
what sort of behaviors to creative
people use and kind of mindsets to they
engage in and then we think about what
you need to do to kind of learn those
skills we can we can have a pretty
robust conversation about how do you
transform your work environment so
design thinking is both a process and a
series of mindsets the design thinking
process starts with empathy we always
say don't start with a problem start
with people people are where the the
interesting data is people are an
interesting thing to observe then we
redefine the problem we ib8 an ideation
is just in a general term for lots and
lots of ways that we have of coming up
with lots and lots of ideas that theory
being with the more ideas you have the
better your choices will be and then we
know that you can't just design in a
vacuum so we like that we have a bias to
action we like to build stuff and test
it and build stuff and test it and then
that way we kind of seek to understand
the problem in a different way even if
you don't use that process you know you
could think like a design thinker you
can think like we think and that is
intended tends to be these five things
and bias to action you'll notice in most
design thinking workshops and in the
training that we do here at Stanford
there's not a lot of planning not
a lot of charting not a lot of stuff
that although it may be useful in
certain domains when you're in the
domain of innovation planning sort of
such things down it comes up to work so
we have a bias to action we tend to
start with actions and then and then
dissect the data we get from those
actions we believe in radical
collaboration which is truly
collaboration across the organizations
across disciplines marketing working
with engineering working with design
working with operations working with the
field salespeople all on the same team
we believe you know that when you get
lots and lots of people together that
have really speak different languages
and come into problems in a different
way you get innovative solutions but you
also get a lot of chaos because people
don't know how to work together and so
we train people on the process as a kind
of anchor to make sure that the team
knows what they're doing and they're
always mindful of how to move forward
curiosity is probably the number one
mindset of a designer and the idea of
reframing problems taking whatever the
problem statement is and really flipping
it upside down expanding it abstracting
and finding ways to approach the problem
that expand the potential solution space
you know when I work with teams to come
to the master class you know I'm
generally impressed with the you know
the smart and dedicated people that show
up and want to do a good job and want to
learn how to do things better and my
premise is if I took any six people and
put them on a team and I gave them a
problem they're all smart neural
motivated and you know plus or minus a
few degrees if everybody's working on
the same problem with a smart motivated
team they're going to get a pretty good
cluster of answers but the answers will
be clustered around some norm the trick
is if I give the one team the design
problem and say go and I take the other
team of sadness and give you some
information those guys don't have and
the information will be a sort of a
nuanced data set about users preferences
and opinions users you know where they
get blocked where they get unblocked and
kind of the kinds of things that might
delight these users and give that team
special that special
information they're going to come up
with much better ideas just because they
reframed the problem you know everybody
else was working on the coffee cup and
they were working on creating the
Starbucks experience which is really a
completely different problems when we
talk about reframing it's a super
powerful tool and we're going to get
into that a little bit in this talk as
we talk about you know what we can
actually accomplish in the next 20
minutes or so to talk about this process
so when people say I just break it down
for me in five minutes what's this whole
design thinking about it to just
remember two things we can't remember
the whole thing and the five mindsets
and the you know five steps and whatever
just remember two things
empathy and brainstorming empathy
because we're going to start with people
not the problem we're not going to we're
not going to solve the problem of
building a better wheel barrel a better
office chair better something we're
going to go out and look at people in
offices and figure out what their
behaviors are we're going to go watch
construction guys on a jobsite move
stuff around and see how they how they
do it and then we're going to take that
data and we're going to come up with
lots and lots I mean lots of ideas
hundreds of ideas not one or two that we
choose from but literally hundreds that
we choose from and the ideas will be
because of the process we use we'll some
will be close to existing solutions and
some will be completely different
solutions completely reframing the
problem so if we're just going to focus
on these for this talk right now because
I think it's where I can give you one or
two tools that are instantaneously
actionable in your organization and and
with that kind of a brief intervention
maybe you can get something going that
won't you that you'll find useful so
essentially the empathy step is we steal
from the tools of the anthropologists
and ethnographers and we do a lot of
observation and we ask lots of questions
and then we come back with all this sort
of interesting observational data we
take videos of people we and we ask them
lots of questions and we just observe
there we do what we call a moccasin walk
we'd spend a day with our users to try
to understand what's really going on
users are interesting people of course
they're going to try to help you when
you ask them questions and they're
actually going to try to please you and
tell you the things that you want to
hear they're also going to tell you
about the ways they think their job
should be not the way it actually is
they're going to they're going to tell
you about the aspirational qualities of
the problem they're working on how good
they're at it but when you actually
observe them and watch how they do all
these little workarounds and and how
they have difficulties understanding you
know how the software really works or
how they opened the product really
functions you get a lot of information
but the thing that we find is that
without putting that information into a
couple of different frameworks it's
really hard to decide what's actionable
and what's not so the one in the one
empathy framework that I think is the
most accessible and it's a pretty
straightforward idea is we have an
overall framework and this is just a
little chunk of it where we put a two by
two together where we go from concrete
to abstract and then on the horizontal
axis its analysis on the left and
synthesis on the right and there's a
complex method of filling out this
framework but the one I want to look at
is when we're trying to get some
insights from our observation we have a
couple of different techniques over in
this top left quadrant we digesting
customer and user needs at the abstract
level we do a thing called an empathy
map that I'm going to show you and we do
if we use the hierarchy of needs
Maslow's hierarchy of needs in a
specific way to try to capture
information and framework it in a way
that we can do something with we have a
bunch of other techniques as well but
I'm not going to go into those right now
so there's a classic a little diagram I
think it comes from the ideal guys and
what you see on the left is sort of the
external world of this mythical user
what you see on the right is the
internal world of this user and here's
here's the sort of truism when you add
in the world and you talk to people who
are using your products you want to come
up with better ideas for your products
or your services your financial services
whatever the experiences that you've
designed for your customers all you can
really get out of them is you can
observe what they do their actual
behaviors the way in which they work and
the workaround
they have and you can talk to them and
you can hear what they say but we never
believe that what they say and what they
do is actually what's going on we
believe that what's really going on is
what they're thinking but the thoughts
behind the way they framed what they say
including trying to please you or trying
to look better than they really are and
then what they do is really not so as is
really drew their behaviors are really
driven by their feelings and a lot of
times there's a mismatch between what
someone feels about a situation what
they say about the situation so a very
simple framework it tends to really open
up this design space and really be
productive is this simple little
two-by-two you go out in the world and
you write down on a sticky note or in
your notebook all the things you saw
people doing let's say we were talking
about where the wheel barrel company we
want a new wheel barrow first of all
you'd never ask for a new wheel barrow
because that's a wheel barrow as a
solution not a problem the problem is
how do I move stuff around the job site
and get it to where people need it when
they need it on time you know it's
always delivered you know to the edge of
the job site on a big pallet all the
bricks are over there but the Claire's
they're somewhere else
so you never frame the problem around
the solution which is the wheel but you
say how do we move stuff around so you
got in a job site and you watch what
people do you watch how they move stuff
around and sometimes they use
wheelbarrows and sometimes they don't
and sometimes they come up with very
creative ways of sort of jury-rigging
wheelbarrows to do things they were
never intended to do and then you
interview them and you find out what
what they say about what they're doing
but then the design team takes those
those observations and maybe you've had
three or four people but do three or
four different observations so then you
write them all down on post-it notes and
you do cluster them in the do column and
in the say column maybe some things
overlap maybe some things are completely
contradictory people said completely
different things different users had
completely different needs so you
cluster those on the left side of the
diagram and then the the insight part
the creative part is you now you have to
sort of make a guess it's truly I guess
it's me we call it design intuition
that's what they said but what are they
really thinking you know I'm sure you've
had this experience
is where you know you people have said
something that they root but it really
came from a deeper internal story or
thought so when you break down the
observations this way you find that on
the right-hand side if you figure out
what their guess what they're thinking
and guess what they're actually feeling
the feelings are the emotions
surrounding things that feelings have to
do with how the behaviors are mapped
into their internal world for instance I
think one of the thing I was at Apple
for seven years working on the notebooks
that devil did in the early and mid 90s
our observation the general observation
that Apple's built around is that
technology makes people feel stupid
you're using a Windows machine or some
other kind of an Android machine
nowadays or something and you're trying
to get a simple task done like somebody
asked me what's Ryan's phone number
while I'm on a call with you know with a
Corinne and I got to look up his phone
number while I'm simultaneously talking
and on every other phone on the planet
what would you do you would say well I'm
probably going to hang up on you but
I'll give it a try and then you try to
sort through menus and then you would
hang up on the person and you know and
the phone would make you both feel
inadequate and stupid because it was
clearly your fault not the phone's fault
that you couldn't find the data you
wanted and you took that feeling and
internalized it as a sort of overall
sense that I'm not good at technology
when when that's the Nats the key once
you want you to discover that story that
feeling and what's going on behind the
actions you realize oh I can make you
fall in love with my product if I don't
make you feel stupid if I make you feel
powerful and so all of Apple's work is
really you know just focused around that
idea of putting the hand the power in
the hands of the user and making the
actions so transparent that you don't
have to learn them you just know how to
do them right so looking up a phone
number on a iPhone with a big graphics
screen and the numbers you know
scrolling in a and
you know at the end of a simple touch
interaction you never feel stupid
so you can use empathy mapping as a
general case for whatever observations
you've made and the insights come from
looking at the thoughts and the feelings
that you can ply from the actions and
the words another way to you know
another way to map things sort of
according to the human need again you
know we don't start with a problem we
start with the people so we go out and
we talk to bricklayers and carpenters
and stuff from the job site or we talk
to cell phone users we have a theory
that every action every interaction
every product actually touches on all
five levels of the hierarchy of needs
this is you know Abraham Mansell's
worked from a long time ago you know I
think current psychology indicates that
although he thought this was a hierarchy
and you needed to fulfill psychological
safety you know love and belonging needs
before you could fulfill esteem or self
actualization that we now know that
that's not true you can you can actually
still be struggling with you know you
know your basic safety and and
physiological needs you can be very very
poor but still be executing art at a
very high level in order to create you
know self actualization but our theory
in using this is that you just take any
action you've seen and you map it
against all of the layers because every
action has something to do with how you
feel about yourself every action has
something to do with creating you know
some sort of sense of safety or
psychological or physical and every
action that you do to go in you're
interacting with products or services
can create senses of self-esteem create
senses of belonging
what are brands brands are just you know
things you belong to you belong to them
you believe as you don't buy wranglers
you buy Apple you don't buy value by you
know you like Disney you don't like
Nickelodeon so you know you're always
belonging to something in the consumer
culture and it's always around some kind
of a need and oftentimes the only
observations you have may
and one or two of these frameworks are
one of the true these layers but what
you do is you then through that design
intuition thing that that creative leap
to say well how does this tool that the
carpenter is using actually create
self-actualization and self-esteem for
the carpenter when it looks like it's
simply just about you know creating a
easier way to do a task and those those
conceptual leap soft and again just like
with the empathy map unlock a possible
observation or at least a point of view
that you can now prototype test and see
what see what what new innovation will
come out of it so basically what both of
these frameworks do is they argue
they're arguing that in every product in
every interaction and every service or
experience that you that you offer your
customer consumer whether it's designed
or not it is it is a it's a it's an
experience that has touchpoints
experience that they go through and that
it is not simply the rationalization of
I wanted something you provided it I
bought the product or service I used it
we're done it's always about the
internal state emotional state of the
user and if you and since you cannot
observe people don't have glass heads
and they don't tell you what their
emotional interstate is all about you
you become expert again using the tools
of ethnography observation putting
yourself you know in an empathetic
situation walking in their shoes doing
what they do you put yourself in a
situation to understand the emotional
needs of that are behind the physical or
observable actions and once you've
understood that using these frameworks a
whole bunch of new ideas become possible
and then you use the brainstorming and
prototyping and testing process to see
which of your insights turn out to prove
true so it although it's those two
primers are pretty simple you know say
do versus thing feel put things on the
hierarchy of needs
they're actually one we don't notice
most people don't do those unless
they're trained in design thinking bait
they execute a functional solution but
they don't execute a solution that
delights or engages a user in a deep way
you know I'm I teach in the design
school I teach engineers how to do great
design we do come from a sort of you
know strict design tradition form does
follow function the way we teach it but
remember the you know the form follows
function one of the functions of objects
in our built world particularly in the
technological world where objects can be
increased and click difficult and opaque
and hard to use one of the functions of
objects is to delight us one of the
functions of objects is to be beautiful
so that our built world is a beautiful
place it's not simply the you know the
old Bauhaus Germanic notion that
function was strictly the mechanical
function of the product to resolve the
you know the need of the strict usage
because there is no such thing with
human beings as you know it's just the
usage it's always about how the person
feels and so when you open up your
design process to the empathy step it
really changes the information you have
to design with and we find that that's
one of the major things that leads to
innovation ok so if you've got if you've
got if you're the team that's got all
this new data about how users think and
feel and what they actually how the
product even the simplest little product
contributes to their self-actualization
or self-knowledge an awareness and then
projection of themselves in the world is
competent and intelligent people now
you've got to come up with lots of ideas
and here's the other just again when I
only have a little bit of time this is
the other one I hit on my particular
brainstorming we have lots of techniques
for ideation but particularly I want to
talk about brainstorming because because
so many people do it so wrong and and
then they don't get the results they
want and then they blame brainstorming
is the process and the studies on
brainstorming that have said
brainstorming doesn't work are flawed
a number of ways but brainstorming can
really not work when you don't do it
correctly or you don't do it well but
when it is done properly it creates the
opportunity to generate hundreds of
ideas and number one thing we see when
we're looking working with startups
working with large companies doesn't
matter the scale people grab the first
idea or the first couple of ideas and
run with and and ninety-nine out of a
hundred times those first couple of
ideas are the things that are available
to you they're the things you know how
to do and so by definition they're not
innovations they're line extensions
they're small increments on the existing
ideas of products but by definition
they're the first thing that was
available to you to your thinking which
are the team's thinking and they are not
innovative enough and people truncate
the process because they want to get
into implementation implementation
always feels good even when you're
implementing the wrong thing your bills
just love you know organizations love to
see action action looks like
implementation and over and over again
we see people implementing essentially
mediocre ideas with gusto and then
wondering why you know they didn't they
didn't move the bar on the sales meal or
on the innovation needle so here's what
what we say brainstorming is this
complicated thing it's really about the
mind-body relationship it's about
engaging more intelligence than just
your intellectual intelligence you have
kinesthetic intelligence you have
emotional intelligence which we were
just talking about the whole empathy
pieces about amplifying the emotional
intelligence and information in that
spectrum you have information about
cultural things you have information
about physical things all of that gets
employed in a robust brainstorming
process and I like to use the analogy to
jazz because if you think about what a
jazz ensemble does it gets together and
it innovates in the moment it tries to
play songs in a way that it's never been
played before but everybody's playing
the same song and everybody's trying to
sort of solve the same problem and I
love this analogy because when I see
people getting together for
brainstorming and they aren't
prepping properly there they're not
they're not assembling the team properly
it sort of feels to me kind of like a
jazz ensemble that's disorganized right
so I happen to be a jazz fan kind of
blue is the best-selling jazz album of
all time it was an all-star cast pulled
together by Miles Davis Bill Evans on
piano Jimmy Cobb on drums Paul Chambers
Cannonball Adderley John Coltrane Miles
Davis these were the Titans of jazz in
that era and when they came together
they were able to create something that
nobody had ever created before and just
you know kind of blow the socks off of
the jazz world now imagine you know I
say hey Ryan let's get together and play
some jazz and you've never played a
saxophone before but here's your
saxophone and Corinne here sure um I
want you to play drums and I want you to
sit in with Bill Evans and Miles Davis
you know it's going to be pretty
impossible for you to even play the
instruments much less get to the level
where you can play the instrument so the
mechanics disappear and what you're
actually doing is playing off of the
other musicians and expanding and
growing the ideas you know that are
being presented musically in the moment
you know in a temporal framework you got
to stay on track on the music you can't
stop the music in the middle and go what
note am I supposed to play now I mean so
the mechanics of brainstorming are
exactly identical to the mechanics of
great jazz you have to be expert at your
instrument your instruments your brain
you have to be willing to be free and
connected in the moment to every idea
that's on the table and you have to be
able to respond you know without critic
internal criticism or external criticism
and your goal is to make something
happen that you had no idea of when you
started and so the mechanics of this are
difficult and even perfect mechanics do
not make great improvisation I know lots
of people who are great you know
mechanical musicians who cannot
improvise apparently this is a 10,000
hour problem I mean I see people sitting
down to brain
and they don't do it very much and they
haven't done it a lot and they've not
really ever gotten past a sort of novice
stage of improvisation if you believe in
the 10,000 hours to mastery I'm going to
get it if you haven't done you know
really good structured brainstorming
with facilitation to make sure that
you're doing it well for at least 100
hours you're still not even competent
and to move from competent experts
probably going to take you a thousand
hours so even if you brainstorm three
hours a week every week on your job
right you know that's only going to get
you 150 hours and so when you sit down
to brainstorm make sure you're
brainstorming with people who are at
least expert or at least competent at
this so that you have the opportunity to
take the combined competencies and
create some music nobody's ever heard
before so this discipline of letting go
and inventing in the moment really takes
quite a bit of practice it's not as
simple as people make it it's not just
sitting in a room tossing out ideas
that's not making music so brainstorming
is effective but it works a couple of
unique ways one the session that you
have generates ideas in itself and if
you do it correctly the session isn't
over until you've sort of then ranked
those ideas but the session is also
fodder for later thinking whatever came
up in the session still exists it's sort
of a live discussion that happens even
after and so oftentimes when people
measure the output of brainstorming
sessions they're not measuring what
happens 24 48 72 hours later and the
other big thing about brainstorming
it's a impact on your work process is
today we come in and brainstorm Monday
is the day we do brain start we do a
really structured brainstorming to two
hours in the morning the charts in the
afternoon that's really different than
today is the day we come in and do
planning today is the day we come in and
do budgeting it's a different behavior
and once it becomes a normal behavior
and normative behavior in your
organization you've started to move the
organization from saying the most
important clearly the most important
thing we do in the organization is what
we spend the most time on right so if we
spend the most time on planning it must
be that we're not a product organization
we're planning organization there's a
great quote from
the former CEO for dalla malaise who
came from one of the young engineers at
Ford
he said culture eats process for lunch
and he was talking to this young
engineer what do you mean by this well I
thought I'd join when I joined for it I
thought I was during a car culture I
want I wanted to design cars I wanted to
talk about the Mustang I wanted to talk
about cars I've been here three years
I've been in planning meetings tollgate
meetings I've been in lots of meetings
but none of these meetings have we ever
talked about a car so clearly we're not
a car culture and I just do a quick
assessment around your own organization
take it a call to take your calendar
from last week add up the amount of time
you did different activities planning
budgeting you know creative innovative
activities done things and the thing you
spent the most time on is the thing that
evidently your organization values the
most because that's where it's spending
all the time and money when you change
out some of those behaviors for
brainstorming a new norm is established
and a shift in the culture is
established because you're saying
something else has value but the other
real reason brainstorming hasn't been as
effective maybe in some places as it
could be is that it's not really kind of
doing it the way we think you should do
it
brainstorming actually has four parts to
it only one part of the brainstorming
session most people skip the other three
so here are the four parts dreaming the
problem warming up the actual brainstorm
which is what everybody says they're
doing even though they don't necessarily
do it that well but that's the thing and
then they tend to stop right there and
then they don't do the next step which
is grouping and selecting ideas so you
got to frame a good problem right
framing is actually really the reframing
thing it's the coming up with something
that's that's open-ended enough so that
a large number of ideas can exist under
that question but setting a goal without
describing the solution you know saying
how can I move bricks or construction
materials from here to there on a
jobsite is a very different question
than how do I make a better wheelbarrow
making a wheelbarrow is a noun and then
noun is always a solution reframed
question a good question for a
brainstorm is always about an action
Reverb if you have a noun in york in
your framing question you've described a
solution and it's not going to work it's
not it's a it's not it's not a subtle
difference it's actually a huge
difference the difference between saying
designing wheelbarrows and getting more
versions of the noun versus designing a
new method or process for transporting
materials completely different problem
so you want to ask an open-ended
question use a verb not a noun but if
you're too abstract nothing happens and
we also see people saying trying to you
know Bowie ocean solve world peace make
everybody happy
those aren't questions that can get any
traction on that's like you're trying to
improvise the jazz but you haven't
picked a song yet you need a song you
need something that focuses the energy
of the group but but the big big errors
are you to making it too big or making
it actually brainstorming the solution
at the problem warming up
people are going to come from the budget
meeting or they're going to come from
right now it's it's finals week at
Stanford pretty soon so never try to
brainstorm during finals week because
people's brains are just not in that
mode right then you know but you do need
to move people from their analytic mind
to their synthetic mind from the
critical focused attention which is a
powerful thing to have in business to a
non-judgmental open focus which is a
powerful thing to have when you're
trying to do innovation and that's not a
transition that's made easily we did
intend to do warm-up exercises we steal
a lot from improv comedy we steal a lot
from theater we steal a lot just just
from ceilings right if you come to most
um these school classrooms it almost
looks like a kindergarten because we
have playdough and popsicle sticks and
and pipe cleaners and construction paper
and little scissors but we get people in
a building mode we give them play clay
and we have them play and we do other
things to sort of move them out of their
critical to their analytic or to their
non-judgmental synthesis focus in the
brainstorm itself we find that if you
have a central facilitator who's writing
down all the ideas it goes too slowly
typically a brainstorming - team is too
two-five don't go much more than five or
six or you just can't get enough
conversation going rapidly enough think
about it you know you never see jazz
improvisational jazz groups that are
bigger than six by the time they get to
eight twelve fourteen it's not really
improvisational anymore they're playing
off a score you got to be able to see
each other and react to each other so
you know in human beings that's about a
five person circle no bigger than that
but in order for that to be very
generative and for the be lakhs of ideas
everybody has to be able to write down
and post their own they write them and
post them in in rapid sequence and that
gets rid of the bottleneck of the
facilitator and then we have the rules
you got a different judgment you got to
go for volume stay on track one
conversation at a time the more you draw
the more visual you are the better
headline which just means describe the
idea really quickly and let somebody
else get their idea up don't don't say
it's a wheelbarrow that has a motor and
the motor has this other thing on it and
it's got the transmission with just say
motorized wheel barrow and go you want
to build up the idea of others and stay
on topic you've heard all these things
before encourage wild ideas let me tell
you why they're there and why they work
you you defer judgment because the
number one thing that crushes human
creativity is fear you're afraid you'll
be called out to be stupid you're afraid
you'll say something that's offensive
you're afraid you'll say something
that's so weird that people will look at
you funny it and if we don't make a safe
space and disconnect the fear motivation
your pre sensor ideas even before you
know you've had them literally things
won't even come into consciousness
because you'll be in a state of fear we
measure people in a brain scanner and we
notice the amygdala is firing we noticed
a fight or flight or freeze response is
firing when that is happening it is
almost impossible to be creative so
you've got to enter for judgment and let
people feel safe in order to have the
kinds of ideas that you want to have
your visual because you want to give
voice to nonverbal thinking about 60% of
your brains a visual processor a lot of
ideas show up as engines but they can't
be put into words so sketching is a
great way to have more ideas it doesn't
matter how well you sketch just you know
crazy little you know cartoons are
better
then really elaborate sketches building
on the ideas others loaner lowers his
ownership barrier so we're all having
ideas and I'm allowed to build on top of
Renza is or currents ideas it's fine it
wasn't my idea in the first place so I'm
not attached to it I'm not going to be
afraid if it's too crazy I just it was
Ryan's crazy idea not mine I just made
it weirder and I like the idea of
encouraging stealing this is the one
place square where if you don't have an
idea just wait for somebody else to have
an idea that's what happens in a jazz
group Miles Davis starts playing a riff
from you know somewhere my prince will
come and then somebody else starts
playing Surrey with the fringe on top
and the two on top of those things and
somebody comes on top of that with
another another riff for another notion
of a son and that whole thing is what's
the beautiful thing it's not just the
one idea at a time you've probably been
in brain storms just before chart bad
where everybody has one idea at a time
we call this popcorn brainstorm
everything you know I just just explode
randomly from the center of the group
when you use a yes and methodology out
of improv yeah I just get better and
better much faster and encouraging wild
ideas because there's always groupthink
in any group there's always the sort of
stereotypical thinking people show up at
a brainstorming session with a whole
bunch of ideas they've already had and
they want to tell you those ideas great
let them get better those that those are
typically the ideas I refer to as the
junk people come with great get them all
on the board post them all and then go
way beyond those right David Kelly's you
know famous for saying look if you don't
go beyond the normal you can't come back
to anything innovative so you don't know
you've gone across the line until your
way across the line and so we'll change
up brainstorming for saying imagine
there's no gravity and we're on the moon
or imagine you're a purple elephant how
would you solve this problem we're just
looking for crazy ideas that that then
we're going to execute those but that
those will stimulate ideas farther from
the center that can be made actionable
so that's why we have those those things
I here's the thing that this is the one
that just kills me people go in a room
maybe if they even warm up maybe they
brainstorm fantastically beautiful music
has been made but somebody forgot to
turn on the tape recorders and we have
no record of it at all what actually
happens mostly is people take a picture
of the whiteboard there's all these
post-its on the whiteboard it's like
yeah I'll take a picture of the
whiteboard and that's where I just go to
die they live
on cell phone cameras pictures of
hundreds of post-its on a whiteboard and
nobody does anything with them so it's
perfectly reasonable for your boss to
say I think this is a waste of time what
did you guys accomplish oh we had a
bunch of ideas why it was really great a
lot of fun you know we had candy and we
did this fun warm-up improv thing it's
like well what happened so you don't
want to be judging during the brainstorm
but right after the brainstorm is the
perfect time to group and select ideas
that look promising now here's the deal
if you just select you know first lots
of ideas overlap and so you that one of
these you put them on posters you can
kind of cluster all the ideas about
changing the way the field service
organization works and cluster all the
other ideas about the way you know
wheelbarrows have two wheels or five
wheels or ten wheels and then you start
and then you start overlaying you know
some questions on the ideas because what
you want to walk away with when your
boss says what happened in the
brainstorming sessions you know we had
142 ideas we down selected those into
six categories that we think you know
have something to do with our business
model well we've got one wildcard
category that we think has got the most
innovative stuff in it and we down
selected from that to five things you
want to prototype and try with customers
that get you promoted that kind of you
know talking about what happened in the
brainstorm is how you make it proactive
and useful and here's the deal if you
just select for the ideas that are
feasible you're back to doing the stuff
that you knew you can do before you got
in the room so you got to pick a
different selection criteria we
particularly like most delightful
because delightful brings in the
customers voice brings in that thing is
going to just make somebody go oh I got
to have that I didn't know I wanted that
but I got to have that now there's a
rumor that Apple does know there's no
research or market stuff is that true
Apple does more research with customers
anybody on the planet they don't ask
customers if they should do a phone but
they do once they get their idea to do a
phone they research the heck out of it
because there they are they're after
that delightful customer experience
that's experience where you didn't even
know you wanted the darn thing as soon
as you see it try it you have to have it
so grouping and selecting is critical
pick a criteria that makes sense the
takeaways are if you change the way you
work and you change the time you spend
on these new behaviors you will actually
change
the outcomes of work and also
everybody's experience of it things you
focus on practicing empathy that leads
to each side empathy that leads to
insights and move to the Jazz
brainstorming model I like to call it
and then if you personally model the
behavior you want from your team you act
differently and you reward differently
you're going to discover that that work
has transformed is transforming itself
into a much more creative and innovative
experience and by the way it takes about
eight weeks to create a new behavior the
behavioral psychologists tell us I'm
seven weeks into my new diet I'm not
sure I'm there yet but it does take a
while to transform behaviors and
organizations but if you just actively
you know you think everybody should act
pretty soon they will change their
behaviors to be what you're looking for
well there's a couple there's a couple
that are pretty pretty tactical and
lemme answer those first question came
in sure we have a facilitator while
brainstorming and I think my
recommendation is you always have
someone who's organized a brainstorm
who's you know you always have Miles
Davis we're going to play this song
we're going to work on this problem and
the person who actually is very careful
about selecting that multidisciplinary
team that's going to brainstorm together
so that's what the facilitators role is
they're not the bottleneck in the idea
having our idea recording so I've really
should be putting things together and
bringing their own ideas down on
post-its and posting it individually but
yeah there is a there isn't typically a
person who calls the session and
organizes the and just the framing and
organizing of ideas at the end and a
report out to whoever the stakeholders
are can you get can I get give you an
example of a kind of insights that I
realized from the empathy effort well
you know here's the thing you know I
always say you don't start with the
problem you start with people but of
course everybody just starts with a
problem even at the d.school you know we
have a class called the proneural design
for extreme affordability where we're
trying to work on the big questions
poverty infant mortality food supply
particularly in the developing world and
there was a team that was given a
problem to go to Nepal and design really
inexpensive low costing cue
because incubators and us incubators you
know made in the technological world of
40 50 60 $70,000 things and there was a
theory that that the third world or
developing nations couldn't afford
incubators so we needed a low-cost one
design $100 incubator a $500 incubator
so this team got all together used their
design thinking skills went over to the
Stanford ICU unit looked at how
incubators and immature babies you know
are connected came up with some plans
and then they put in Nepal when they got
there the doctor they were supposed to
be working with said well these are
really dumb ideas and you don't
understand the problem come with me and
he took them to the ruins of the room
where the babies would be kept and he
said what do you notice in this room and
they said well you have lots of
incubators this yeah I get incubators
donated anytime I want that's not the
problem what else do you notice and one
of the kids finally said where are all
the babies he goes yeah there's no
babies in the hospital babies aren't
born in hospitals and Nepal they're born
in villages come with me eight hours in
a Jeep down a dusty road to a village
where they met three women who had just
you know in the last six months lost
their babies and they realized one they
had the wrong problem too they need to
detect these women to find out what was
really going on what was really going on
is because of bad prenatal care low
birth weight babies are born low birth
weight just means they're compromised
and that they can't regulate their body
temperature the reason they need to be
an incubator simply because if they are
if they aren't kept warm they literally
die of hypothermia will it reframe the
problem that's the embrace company they
started a company out of this they make
an infant's essentially a sleeping bag
that you can suck an infant in you boil
a particular chemical in a pot of water
you stick that in the sleeping bag and
you can keep it in from warm at body
temperature for you know the eight to
twelve hours it takes to get to a
hospital but just recognizing one that
the problem was incorrectly frames to
that they were willing to break out of
the framing of the NGO that they were
working with three it's just actually
talking to the women and finding out
well their first designs were little
boxes and the women said no that looks
like a coffin I'm not going to put my
baby in that and then it was like you
know you can't just take the baby to the
hospital you got to take the baby the
mom and the whole family to the hospital
because it's not like she's going to
drop the kids at daycare that doesn't
exist so the whole iteration of that
design and really understanding who the
user was it took nine months to a year
they've shipped hundreds of thousands of
these baby sleeping bags and and saved
they believe hundreds of thousands of
babies in the process last one is going
to prote this to your boss how do you
get how do you get people to want to try
you know try something like this
there was also a question about
incentives what do you have to do for
incentives so organizations are just
like people they're fearful you need to
lower fear the way you lower fear is a
boss is you change the incentives
because your team's going to fail it's
going to fail a lot when they're trying
to do innovation that the whole notion
of innovation is to do something that's
never been done before what do you think
the success rate on that is well if
you're a venture capitalist and you're
famous in the valley your success rate
is one in ten so if you're not willing
to act like a venture capitalist you're
not ready for innovation it would be one
argument so what the boss can do it is
always change the incentive we actually
do incentives for failure for what we
call good failures failures so you'll
learn a lot from that are highly
generative so that's what a boss can do
how do you convince the boss to try this
stuff it's almost always you pick a
small project that's not on the critical
path it might even just be let's
redesign how we do purchase artists
around here let's redesign how we do
expense reports around here because it's
such a pain in the ass right pick
something is that critical path
demonstrate that a team can work this
way and then through a series of
prototypes you know asking interesting
questions that you actually get to a
more interesting problem than the
problem of you know expense reports and
once you've demonstrated it's
successfully in a couple of small things
you'll be given permission to do
something bigger almost always we find
when this organizations flip from a
planning based organization to a design
thinking our creativity based
organization it comes because somebody
up top was willing to give a team a
little bit of leeway to triumph
fail and give them some air cover some
protection from the rest of the
organization but that a team kind of
took it on themselves to transform their
behavior so you have this little cell of
new behavior that starts to be
successful it starts to create some some
recognition in the organization for the
way they're solving problems but they
were protected in their early days by
some visionary manager or boss who can
who can cover for them while they're
doing you know strange things like
innovation I think that's all the time
we have for questions we're in a little
bit over apologize for that I'm going to
turn it back to cringe thank you for
joining us today and if you have any
follow-up questions we will be sending
out a recording of this session within a
week and you can reply to us there with
additional inquiries in regards to the
program as well as any other follow-up
questions thanks again bye-bye